Oh starting to smell like your now the
cretians magnificence is as real as an
olfactory cletus that sends one into
raptures to the pinnacle of sensual
pleasure what my grandmother has always
instilled this sense of pride in me that
girls especially little girls like you
should smell nice so she'd always say
did you wash your cookie make sure you
scrape a hail-mary cookie so now I spray
perfume near my cookie I just care that
I don't smell bad if I pee I do use like
different perfume to try a different
mood with the difference now they do
bring me different feelings smell is
specialty I'm thinking it's not gonna
smell too bad like I think they're just
trying to be dramatic
I am also dramatic so should I smell it
sorry grandma Oh No oh no oh my god it
smells like a wet dog
what is it blood and milk
well why it smells like urine - do
people put this on themselves dude this
is for people it smells like period
right now I like the I don't like the
little bike though it's not that bad
when you get used to it after wearing
this for an hour
I feel repulsive I can breathe in I
taste the blood in my mouth oh I
wouldn't wear this intentionally I'd
wear something but not not this giving
me anxiety I don't know why I feel like
that's such a weird thing to like have
anxiety about smelling bad
it's emotional smell yeah as it feels
like long-distance relationship to take
this away from me
maybe I'm resisting the smell right now
because I don't want to go back to that
part of my life anymore like so smell
like we smell like with Beyonce
[Music]